des femmes entrepreneurs ou porteuses de
projets elle son traiteur à domicile
coach comptable ou encore sophrologue le
ch accompagne les femmes et les hommes
mais les femmes dans la gestion du
stress les problèmes de sommeil de
burnout
elles se retrouvent pour un business
buzz organisé par l'association femmes
entrepreneurs qui regroupe 150 membres
en moyenne ce sont des événements de
réseautage de networking comme on dit en
anglais
l'idée c'est de rassembler les personnes
de les mettre en relation de les faire
se rencontrer
et puis dans en espérer avec le long
terme des synergies des opportunités
michel richer ancien architecte a convié
les adhérentes de l'association femmes
entrepreneures chez elle à poissy elle a
fait les beaux-arts puis a travaillé
pour un fabricant de luminaires pendant
22 ans
passionné par le verre de murano elle a
décidé de lancer sa marque de bijoux
milo gina et moi j'avais envie en fait
de travailler le verre de murano mais
avec l'élégance française avec des
choses plus épuré plus sobre bagues
boucles d'oreilles broches ou encore
collier des créations qu'elle porte sur
elle
je pense que j'ai évolué avec l'âge il
ya vingt ans je me serais pas senti
entrepreneurs je me sentais pas l'âme
d'un autre d'un entrepreneur j'étais
bien en tant que salarié quelque part
j'ai découvert la sécurité les enfants
grandissant les enfants est en partie du
nih et ailleurs acquis de l'expérience
on peut en fait prétendre à saïx était
au deuxième vie qui commence beaucoup de
ces femmes ont une activité de salarié
pour certaines c'est une reconversion
suite un changement de vie un divorce ou
encore un retour d'expatriation
ça fait maintenant quatre ans je fais
partie
et ça a été une très grande aide pour
moi lors de cette rencontre chacune
pitch son business en une minute
l'occasion de partager leurs expériences
je me suis inscrite pour pouvoir
rencontrer du monde
au niveau local et puis au niveau des
femmes il ya une grosse dynamique et une
émulation et entraide entre entre les
femmes l'association a édité un livre
des créatrices et femmes entrepreneurs à
l'ouest de paris afin de promouvoir ses
membres au delà des événements organisés
toute l'année